recently I was given a periodic table
clock which I began by thinking was
quite fun
I now realize it's amazing so it was a
present from a Japanese school teacher
but before I explain to you why it's so
good we need to go back to the
conventional periodic table beginning
with hydrogen down to element 118 and
these elements are organized by their so
called
atomic number hydrogen is one helium is
to lithium three and so on all the way
down to 100 1500 and 1600 and 1718 now
one of the problems is that even I as a
chemist cannot remember the atomic
numbers of more than a few elements
without looking at the periodic table so
you can see here 34 zinc or 79 for gold
the atomic number is the number of
protons in the nucleus it is a key
aspect of the periodic table therefore
it's quite irritating that you can't
just look at the periodic table quickly
and get the number without staring at
the small print and this is where the
clock comes in for people who at least
my age and probably younger who used to
clocks we can read the time on a clock
very accurately we know precisely when
it's 19 minutes past the hour or 55
minutes past the hour or whatever the
clever idea of this clock which was
thought up by the chemistry teacher at
the Japanese school
Nagisa Oh Gnawa he realized that you
could exploit this way that people know
the numbers to get the atomic numbers so
what is done is one minute past the hour
he is put H for hydrogen and he's gone
all the way around 260 which is near dim
iam he's gone all the way around a
second time
258 plus 60 that's two minutes before
the hour to put element 100
18 so what it means is that without
really having to think I can see that
say phosphorus which is at quarter past
the hour is atomic number 15 and rhenium
which is in same place is 60 plus 15 so
it's atomic number 75 similarly rhodium
here is atomic number 45 and dubnium is
60 plus 45 is 105 so this is the first
periodic table that I've ever seen
where you can work out the atomic number
without thinking now there are many
things you can't do with this you can't
see that sodium potassium cesium and so
on have similar chemical properties but
if you want a periodic table that will
tell you the atomic number and tell you
the time this is the one for you well I
have it I use it as a clock and I have
it on my desk and it's greatly admired
by lots of people professor you already
have a periodic table clock as a
periodic table clock up there so that
one's fun it does the first 24 elements
for the first 24 hours of 1 to 12 so
magnesium is 12 and then from aluminium
round to chromium chromium is 24 I think
this one if it was up on the wall then
um the letters would be too small you
couldn't really read it so this is
clearly an alarm clock for real
chemistry enthusiasts you could have it
by your bed and wake up and sit and look
at the atomic numbers so I think they
both have their place
you